[Musique]
est ce que j'attends de ce voyage c'est
surtout un moment inoubliable entre
camarades et professeurs eux aussi
apprendre un peu plus rapide sur pouvoir
voir visiter un peu le monde avec brice
que je suis déjà là et j'aimerais aussi
découvrir la végétation leur façon de
vivre leur nourriture et tout ce qui va
avec la câlinerie un peu plus que les
responsabilise amis es dans les boîtes
chose voilà une bien peu les parents à
les vendre web feu et voilà un vrai coup
mon temps déjà pour le voyage donc il va
découvrir quelque chose dont les
capteurs poli à savoir l'arrêt
débrouille à lille et j'ai pas de la fin
de mois donc ma passion de virtuel pas
donc
locaux l'amélie moi comment déjà ok
[Musique]
je pensais que j'allais être fatigué
parce que j'ai pas trop dormi dans
l'avion mais finalement hyper contente
d'être arrivée à paris et hâte de
prendre les deux prochains vols pour un
enfant arrive à 14 j'ai pas vraiment
beaucoup dormi dans l'avion mais je suis
vraiment hyper contente d'avoir fait
cette étape parce que ça nous rapproche
encore plus du projet le projet est
enfin en marche ça fait bizarre ça
faisait très longtemps qu'on attendait
ça mais ça va ça à mes la forme je suis
assez content après c'est la première
fois que j'ai à paris du coup sévère
c'est le premier grand vol que j'ai fait
deux à chaque fois que je crois la
russie se croirait à maurice du coup la
paix c'est un grand voyage c'est un pays
qu'on pourra pas y aller tous les jours
c'est comment on va le savoir permettre
à aider des gens du coup c'est vraiment
la tribune terre qui va nous changer et
qui va nous transformer et qui va nous
apprenait d'ailleurs ces montagnes qui
font grimper tout là haut on respire
bien
plus peur non
on va faire de la marche doit sa rentrée
et on va litres des naissains aux
enfants là-bas et montrait un peu les
traditions d'ici je suis assez détendu
j'ai pas trop je pas trop stressé mais
après j'ai un peu excité aussi un petit
peu mais après je trouve que le froid
c'est très agréable
ben c'est une expérience
très citroën force en fait c'est nous
apporter plein de connaissances et puis
on va apporter aussi des choses au népal
donc c'est très important aussi
[Musique]
non
il
[Musique]